that's so stupid when I sing nobody's
listening to me
demi lovato made a triumphant return to
performing at the Grammy Awards Sunday
night debuting her new song anyone
[Music]
the singer teared up a few times while
belting the ballad it was her first big
performance since her 2018 overdose
before her emotional return to stage
Demi documented her night on Instagram
and those are just earrings the excited
mom you're nervous yeah it's kind of
like okay you know one of our favorite
fighters is okay
it was obviously a major night for the
27 year old on Friday Demi opened up to
Apple music about her journey back to
the stage it's taken me a long time to
be able to even get this far which is
performing a song that's so vulnerable
to me
Demi revealed the track was actually
written just before she was hospitalized
following her 2018 overdose it was about
a week after I had been in the hospital
and I was finally like awake and and I
just remember hearing back the songs I
had just recorded and thinking if
there's ever a moment where I get to
come back from this I want to sing this
song the Grammy performance is just the
beginning of her musical comeback year
Demi will also be singing the national
anthem next weekend at the Super Bowl
[Music]